I wish strongly yes I need to speak to
in three eyed Raven I don't know what
that means
hey youtubers it's Charlie as requested
this is going to be my brand theory
superpose there's a lot of new theories
based on stuff they're doing in season
seven but this will be a breakdown of
all the big brand fit reason why I think
some of them are true or false some of
them are better than others as you can
see there's a new round of the HBO now
giveaway all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video and I know a lot of people
are talking about the big thing that
happened this morning I will address
that at the end of this but please do
not post spoilers in the comments there
have been a lot of great brand theories
since he debuted with his powers during
season six what can he do what are his
time-traveling abilities the ambiguity
of the show in the lack of more book
material to clarify what he can actually
do has led to some really good theories
the way the TV show is using him right
now is sort of like an exposition potato
he's a potato until they need exposition
he's stuck in that wheelchair at the
mercy of anybody that walks by him in
the courtyard so he could just pretend
to be in a vision if he doesn't want to
talk to someone you'll notice that a lot
of these theories are tied to what brain
is actually able to do with his powers
like he can see things in the past but I
think because of the way that he made
Ned Stark
turn his head as if he sort of heard
someone speaking to him on the wind
people think that he actually can't
interact with people in the past so
people take it a step further and say
well if he can influence things in the
past maybe he can be people in the past
now most of these I do not believe so
the idea that he's Brandon the Builder
is just the idea that it's sort of this
time loop that he's created because of
what he did with Hodor
if he's able to affect Hodor in the past
and in the present simultaneously maybe
he can also do the same thing for the
wall maybe he's a much bigger part of
the cycle of Ice and Fire if he's one of
the most powerful characters in the show
wouldn't it stand to reason that he
would have a role in helping create one
of the most powerful defenses against
the White Walkers it's a really
interesting idea that I don't think
that's going to pan out
it's largely just like I said based on
the ambiguity of the TV show in reality
I think that there was an actual Brandon
the Builder who was a king of winter who
was not brand stark as we see him today
in the role of the three-eyed Raven is
just a completely separate person who
lived thousands of years ago but this
next theory is sort of a spin-off of
that brand secretly being other people
as a result of his time-traveling
abilities bran is all of the brand's you
may have heard this idea is just a next
logical step like a brand is secretly
other people that wouldn't he be all of
the brand's influencing everything in
all time periods so the only reason why
I don't think that that's true is
because I don't think he's Brandon the
Builder and if he's not one of the other
brands and there's no way that he could
be all of the brand's but it's a great
idea it's one of those funnier crackpot
theories some of these are more comedic
than others some of them are actually
based in reality and there's even one
that I legit think is true even though
the TV show would just kind of brush
over it because it's kind of awkward a
little bit gross but the next big one is
that brand made the Mad King go mad by
whispering in his ear trying to stop
things in the past from happening so
bran starts to learn about his abilities
during season six people are like maybe
he's the person that made the Mad King
go mad but the problem is is that you
actually show him slowly going mad over
the course of his lifetime it wasn't
like he was an amazing King cut to
Robert's rebellion and then he just
suddenly decides to blow up all of
King's Landing with wildfire so Jaime
has to kill him and become the
Kingslayer he was a little bit younger
than Jon Snow is right now when he was
crowned King he wasn't as young as
Joffrey but in his early years he was
actually really good he introduced all
these sweeping reforms everybody was
really happy with him but then slowly
over time he started to grow more and
more paranoid showing signs of the
Targaryen madness started to feel like
everyone was plotting against him
everyone in King's Landing was against
him so he slowly became the Mad King
that you see today this is also really
messed up but it's rumored that in his
later years he was also only able to
become sexually aroused after he burned
someone alive so he didn't go from zero
to burn them all overnight with brand
sitting there whispering don't burn them
all maybe you don't burn down King's
Landing
the neck
brand secret identity isn't quite as
crazy but it's also based on time travel
abilities the Bloodraven or the
three-eyed Raven however you want to
think about a mother TV show is really
an older version of brand who's bending
space and time to teach himself his
abilities so obviously I don't believe
this either because even on the TV show
even though the timelines a little bit
different from the way the time moves in
the books he implies he's been doing
this for thousands of years and like I
said I do think that people like Brandon
the Builder people of antiquity the
great figures of the Age of Heroes they
actually existed lived and died
thousands of years ago and that's mostly
based on George our Martin talking about
the night king who says that the
mythical night king who was Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch actually
lived and died a long time ago so he is
not the same person that we're watching
on the TV show even though the TV show
has been a lot more ambiguous about that
sort of the new spin-off crackpot
version of that that I've seen is
actually a pretty fantastical idea which
I don't believe but it's interesting
nonetheless is that brand is going to go
back in time to try and stop or kill the
children of the forest to prevent them
from creating the night king another
spin on the idea brand using his time
travel abilities to change something in
the past and prevent some big
catastrophe from happening but I think
the problem with this is when the
three-eyed Raven says the ink is dry the
past has already been written he's
implying that bran can't actually change
things in the past even though there's a
tangential connection psychically with
things in the past so I don't think that
any of the bad things that have happened
in the past or result of brand making
mistakes trying to change them I don't
think the brain can physically travel to
the past or even possess people's minds
full-blown like he would do for Hodor
like I don't think that he can warg
people in the past although he can touch
their minds which obviously everybody
points to the Hodor scene and says well
if he can't affect the past and how was
he able to mess up hodor mind what I
think the TV show has been trying to say
and I do think that it'll be a lot
clearer in the books when George R
Martin talks about it is that brand is
psychically connected to Hodor in the
past and he's able to scramble his mind
because of the proximity he's into
present-day Hodor so
or in the past might have heard some
whispering on the wind like why is
somebody screaming at me to hold the
door I don't quite understand what this
means
but because present-day Hodor is
experiencing so much trauma in this
moment like he is freaking out here
because the army of the Dead is getting
ready to burst through that door because
he has people at both ends of his
timeline speaking to him it just
completely scrambles his mind so it's
mostly proximity effect but if Jon Snow
were the person that were holding the
door and bran were also looking at young
Jon Snow in the past he could probably
scramble his mind to one of the other
new time-travel there is it's a spin-off
of the idea of him going back in time
and having something to do with the
children before scree the night king is
it bran is secretly the night king
himself I think the reason that this got
started is largely confusion over the
ambiguity of how his powers work and the
idea that the actor that's playing the
night king looks relatively similar to
Isaac Hempstead right his face does look
a little bit like his face but I do
think that this character is a
completely distinct person even though
the TV show version is different from
the book version still completely
different from bran stark even if he
grows up to look like this person he
still can't inhabit people's minds in
the past he can only touch them so he
wouldn't be able to psychically become
this person but what I do think is going
on the theory that I do think has some
basis and truth is that because this is
happening in the north in the children
of the forest we're fighting a war with
the first men they turned a first man
into the night king and because a lot of
the first men of the north share some
DNA with the Starks of Winterfell is
possible that the night king of the TV
show was a stark on some level but I
don't do that he's bran stark and they
just want to let you know that he's his
own person he's not being controlled by
brand trying to warg into the past or
anything crazy like that and it's sort
of like the last funny theory that
everybody's talking about now is bran
just secretly watching everyone in all
time periods have sex at the same time
hello Jon I saw you breaking your vows
in that cave you were so beautiful just
being completely inappropriate he
completely recontextualizes that moment
at the end of the first episode where he
gets pushed out the window by Jaime he
was secretly peeping on them
having sex the crazy thing about this
though is that that's actually true
Brian has all of the information he
knows everything that's happened so
technically he has watched everybody do
this even though it's like having a
giant hard drive you can't understand
everything all at the same time like you
have to focus on very specific moments
so you can make the joke that the
prequel series is just going to be brand
going back in time watching everybody
have sex you could probably get a lot of
people to watch that show but there's
going to be so many more jokes about
brand in the TV show like I said is
going to be very ambiguous there will be
plot holes but what I think is going on
is that brand is just the x-position
potato they wheel them out when they
need exposition all of the big gaps that
you sense are just a result of the
writers trying to create dramatic
tension so we can't tell everybody
everything right away the minute we roll
up to Winterfell because then they'll
have too much information too fast so we
need to draw that out and so they just
leaves the plot holes which obviously
fans fill with big theories about why
he's secretly doing these things so if
you have been reading up on leaked stuff
just please don't post that stuff in the
comments what will happen is there might
be another bonus video Sunday before the
episode drops but congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Killian fairly
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything click here for more footage
from episode 4 and you can click here
for my episode 3 video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight